what joining me now is international
trade Minister Greg hands very good
morning thanks for coming in why is the
chancellor flying back from the IMF in
Washington early well he has been there
for two days he's had extensive meetings
with World Financial leaders Finance
Minister Central Bank Governors uh It's
Not Unusual I've been a government
Minister about 10 years to come back a
day early from an international visit uh
he's coming back for discussions with
colleagues we obviously have the
medium-term fiscal plan coming up on the
31st of October so just in a couple of
weeks time there's work to be done
there's conversations to be had with
colleagues but the major meat of the
meetings of the IMF and the World Bank
have finished and the Prime Minister and
the chances Checker has been there now
for two days I think it's not unusual to
come back a day early so he's coming
back for discussions with colleagues are
u-turns on any aspects of the mini
budget being considered as part of those
discussions well I mean they I saw the
Prime Minister yesterday the Prime
Minister and the chancellor are
absolutely determined to deliver on the
growth plan that is what the country
needs that's what the economy needs uh
the chance they'll be setting out his
plans it's not right for me to speculate
uh just two weeks in advance of those
plans I was a treasury Minister myself
Chief Secretary of the Treasury before I
think we're just gonna have to wait and
see what the chancellor says in the
medium-term fiscal plan on the 31st of
October but it's possible there'll be
reversals well look let's wait and see
you won't have long to wait
um to the 31st of October for the
chancellor to lay out those plans I do
say that the Prime Minister and the
chancellor are absolutely Resolute
determined the growth plan the
centerpiece but we'll have to see some
of the detail including a full forecast
from the office for Budget
responsibility on the 31st of October
let me just ask you about a couple of
aspects because a lot of people it will
affect a lot of people after all what
about the scrapping of the rise in
National Insurance well that definitely
go ahead
they well that's already been voted on
in the House of Commons got voted on on
uh Tuesday or Wednesday evening of this
week
um so that is going ahead uh that's
already been voted on it's already been
okay so that's going ahead what about
the scrapping of the rising corporation
tax then well uh in terms of as I said
the chancellor the Prime Minister
absolutely determined to stick to their
plans but let's wait and for the uh how
this will all pan out in the wider
scheme in the medium term fiscal plan
that you won't have long to wait for
comes before the end of the month do you
rule out any changes to the mini budgets
well I'm not going to speculate on the
medium-term fiscal plan that's going to
be coming on the 31st of October before
the end of the month as I say the Prime
Minister and the chancellor are
absolutely determined Resolute I've
worked very closely uh with both of them
in government I was Liz truss is number
two at trade before
quasi-cuatang's number two at the
business department I know them well and
I know how determined they are to
deliver economic growth deliver on the
growth plan some of the detail The Wider
context will quite rightly have to wait
for for the median term fiscal plan
published on Monday and two weeks so
they want to push ahead with their
growth plan but you talk about the
details some of the detail could change
well I'm saying that some of the detail
will be laid out on the 31st of October
again with the full forecast from the
office of budget responsibility the full
scorecard in a usual Treasury and office
of budget responsibility way working
together working together as it should
be that's a long time to wait the 31st
of October are we not going to get any
update later today will we get an update
today on how the government is going to
respond to the the market turmoil well
look the government will make responses
as appropriate as events happen but the
the the absolutely commitment is to
publish the medium-term fiscal plan this
is looking at how the government is
going to pay for everything how the
government is going to set its budget in
the coming years and that will be laid
out in just two weeks time well yes but
we're in the middle of Market turmoil
the Market's clearly are speculating as
well about whether there'll be changes
to the mini budget not least corporation
tax the George Osborne former Chancellor
of course thinks that decisions should
be made quicker than that let's take a
look at what he tweeted yesterday given
the pain being caused the real economy
by the financial turbulence it's not
clear why it's in anyone's interest to
wait 18 more days before the inevitable
u-turn on the mini budget well look I
used to work for George Osborne for many
years as his chief secretary to the
treasury so I know him well but I do
think the government has been absolutely
clear that the plans the detail plans
will be laid out the medium-term fiscal
plan coming before the end of the month
there's only a couple of weeks the
chancellor of course gave interviews
yesterday in Washington on the current
situation in regards to the global
turmoil and financial markets of course
there's a not something happening just
in the UK there are some specific UK
things going on but there is a global
problem going on with the both the rise
in Energy prices the rise in global
inflation uh there's been interventions
not only in this country the bank of
Japan has had to intervene the Yen has
fallen to a 30-year low this is not a UK
only thing but as you say there are
elements that are absolutely specific to
the UK and useful to Richie sunac in his
campaign for leadership and he said it
would be complacent and irresponsible to
ignore the risks of the markets losing
confidence in the British economy he
also warned that what he described as
Liz truss's unfunded spending
commitments he said they would force up
inflation and interest rates and
increase borrowing costs he was right
wasn't he well I mean different things
were said during the conservative
leadership contest which of course is a
entirely natural thing the two
candidates are laid out their approaches
their stalls uh Liz trussa as you
rightly pointed out I voted for Rishi
zunak but this trust why on that contest
she's delivering on the plans
right about what those plans is
delivering on the plans that she laid
out during that leadership contest we've
got more detail to come in the
medium-term fiscal plan uh before the
end of the month and it's right that the
conservative party uh be United behind
our selected conservative party leader
and now prime minister Liz truss would
the markets have more confidence if
Rishi sunak was prime minister as you'd
wanted him to be well there's always
these kind of what if style questions uh
but you know as we know from the
leadership contest uh Richardson act did
not win the leadership contest Liz trust
did win the leadership contest I am
dealing with the situation uh that we
are in which is that Liz truss is our
prime minister she has my confidence she
should have the confidence of all
conservative MPS the whole conservative
party and actually deserves the
confidence of the country as we go into
quite difficult Economic Times with the
rise in energy driven by Vladimir
Putin's invasion of train the turmoil
and Global Financial markets we need to
get behind our prime minister as a party
and show Liz trust the confidence that
she deserves in quasi-quarting to make
these difficult decisions going forward
you say we should have confidence in the
Prime Minister and the chancellor if
there were more changes to the mini
budget there's always already been one
big reversal is quasi-cutting's position
turnable I think totally I mean quasi
kwatang himself said yesterday was 100
sure he will still be in position I know
the Prime Minister has got total
confidence in quasi-karting I've worked
very closely with quasi is an incredibly
capable person a very very bright person
who makes a good judgment calls and I
have absolute confidence that causes
chance of this tracker so if he was to
introduce some kind of change to
corporation tax either reverse his plan
or to to have corporation tax Rise by a
smaller amount you still think that his
he has credibility with the market it
well you're asking me to speculate well
it's the speculation that the markets
are doing that a lot of Tory MPS are
pushing for but it's not right for me to
speculate what I am saying is the prime
minister and the Chance executor are
absolutely determined on their course
and more detail be laid out before too
long in the medium-term fiscal plan on
the 31st of October the times is
reporting that what they describe as
senior conservatives are holding talks
about replacing Liz truss with a joint
ticket of Rishi sunak and Penny Morton
you're shaking your head have you heard
anything about that I don't recognize
that story at all uh I was a supporter
of Rishi zunak over the summer I'd be
very surprised at that story I was
talking only yesterday with Penny
Morton's I I don't recognize that story
at all but what we do need to do is the
conservative party does need to unite to
bind our prime minister she was our
choice of the conservative party just a
few weeks ago we need to Romania United
get together behind Liz truss
quasi-coating as our team even though
her policies have caused turmoil on the
market and seen people's mortgage rates
shoot up well I disagree with that yes
there are some UK specific factors but
overall the uh Global situation caused
originally of course by Vladimir Putin's
Invasion Ukraine the uh also the
recovery of the economy coming out of
the pandemic you know these are a
backdrop across all G7 countries you
know this year and last year the UK is
growing stronger than any other G7
country we are our position we have some
some serious issues coming up but other
countries are facing a similar set of
problems the rise in Energy prices the
turmoil and Global Market intervention
by central banks around the world rises
in interest rates rises in mortgage
rates energy price crunches in different
European countries and there's a lot
going on in the world situation in the
world economy but a lot of economists
including ones at the bank of England
would say this is UK specific well I
think we heard they will take into
account the global factors but they
would say there are some UK specific
problems but we heard in your clip
earlier from the head of the IMF about
global forces and Global turmoil you
know that is the principal focus of the
the IMF meeting that's just been
happening has been looking at those
global forces the interventions that
have been needed some of the problems a
lot of countries are facing with energy
our European neighbors are facing a very
significant crunch on both energy Supply
and energy prices you know these are
something that are not unique to the UK
according and Liz Trask going to be in
their positions in a month's time
absolutely okay Craig Hans we appreciate
your time thanks very much and thank you